russia says it has deployed a new
hypersonic weapon which some defense
analysts say is the latest sign of a new
arms race it reportedly flies at 27
times the speed of sound and can carry a
nuclear warhead the russians say the
avant-garde weapon can make evasive
turns after its fired making many
defense systems useless because it's
impossible to intercept them as they
come back down to earth russia says the
ad vanguard secures its position as a
world leader in hypersonic weapons for
the US and china do say they are
developing similar systems defense
analyst powerful falcon how a tells us
that russia is pushing this announcement
for political reasons the internal
message is growing very very strong on
all the russian TV and other propaganda
outwards that this is Russia's number
one in the world that we have weapons
that no one else has which to some
extent is true and that this sounds good
for the Russian people and mass but also
this the the actual military properties
how much this Russia Myriad's the
Russian security are somewhat questioned
by experts but what the public it goes
down well and also of course in the
United States many experts and the
Pentagon will be also growing out of
proportion
the Russian achievements because they
have their own agenda to present to
Congress and to the public that there's
a Russian threat the Russians are red
and that means they should get more
money from the budget to catch up